das die ganze wahl
[Musik]
mehr
der kinderbetreuung gibt es natürlich
nur noch ein thema das heißt sparen
sparen sparen aber die parteien wollen
den wahlabend so richtig krachen lassen
oder auch nicht zum beispiel gehe zur
spd
[Musik]
die berichterstattung und mein kollege
ist bei der spd
und ich möchte hier nicht damit ich ja
ganz schön keller seien auch mal von aus
[Applaus]
ergebnis nicht schönreden natürlich ist
natürlich auch wieder bundeskanzlerin
[Musik]
könnte uns noch jemand wir bringen
12 36 stück großer physik auf den sich
auch noch ein kita-platz weniger adria
vor kraft es wäre ja mal zeit der platz
insgesamt wird sie erst möglich gemacht
hat norbert röttgen sie sind ein
röntgenbild sozusagen röttgen google ich
bin ein rtl moderator und reporter
dies wird auch durch eine art von arm
haben sie sich schon ein bisschen
absolventen wie vor der kamera will ich
ein bisschen gesungen und die leute
haben nicht schlagartig den raum
verlassen ganz gut zu öffnen
nach dieser historischen wahl
[Musik]
alles klar
entsprechend ist langsam mitleid ehrlich
willkommen jetzt du dir dich trösten
dass mit dem wasser zu trinken hier
rücken von der spd 12 11